>>> SO WE'RE BACK NOWITH OUR
BREANG NEWS TONIGHT, A NEW
TAPE THAT SHOWS KEVIN McCARTHY
WAS NOT TELLING THE TRUTH WHEN
DENIED HAVING SAID HE WOULD CALL
TRUMP AND TELL HIM TO RESIGN, AN
TEMPT TO BOLSTER THE BIG LIE,
THE EXACT THING YOU HEARD OBAMA
TALKING ABOUT, TELLING HIM THAT
HE WOULD RESIGN IN THE WAKE OF
JANUARY 6th, COMING FROM A NEW
BOOK, ALEXANDER BURNS AND
MARTIN, THIS WOULD NOT, THE
TRUMP, BATTLE FOR AMERICA'S
FUTURE, McCARTHY CALLED THE
REPORTING TOTALLY FALSE AND
WRONG BUT TONIGHT THOSE
REPORTERS ARE RELEASING THE
AUDIO OF McCARTHY IN HIS OWN
WORDS.
>> I'M HERE, THANKS KEVIN.
I JUST HEARD THE QUESTION WHEN
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE 25th
AMENDMENT RESOLUTION.
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU ASKED IF IT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT HAPPENS IF IT GETS
THERE AFTER HE'S GONE, IS THERE
ANY CHANCE?
ARE YOU HEARING THAT HE MIGHT
RESIGN, ANY REASON TO THINK THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN?
>> I'VE HAD A FEW DISCUSSIONS.
MY GUT TELLS ME NO.
I'M SERIOUSLY THINKING OF HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION WITH HIM
TONIGHT.
I HAVEN'T TALKED TO HIM IN A
COUPLE OF DAYS.
FROM WHAT I KNOW OF HIM, I MEAN,
YOU GUYS ALL KNOW HIM TOO, DO
YOU THINK HE'D EVER BACK AWAY?
WHAT I THINK I'M GOING TO DO IS
I'M GOING TO CALL HIM.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK, PASS THE
HOUSE, I THINK THERE'S A CHANCE
IT WILL PASS THE SENATE EVEN
WHEN HE'S GONE AND I THINK THERE
ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
RAMIFICATIONS FOR THAT.
NOW I HAVEN'T HAD A DISCUSSION
WITH THE DEMS IF HE DID RESIGN,
WOULD THAT HAPPEN?
THIS IS ONE PERSONAL FEAR I
HAVE, I DO NOT WANT TO GET IN
ANY CONVERSATION ABOUT, AGAIN
ONLY DISCUSSION I DID HAVE WITH
HIM IS THAT I THINK THIS WILL
PASS AND IT WOULD BE MY
RECOMMENDATION YOU SHOULD
RESIGN.
I MEAN, THAT WOULD BE MY TAKE,
BUT I DON'T THINK HE WOULD TAKE
IT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
>> I MEAN HOW MUCH MORE, SO MUCH
FOR THE DENIAL, RIGHT?
CNN REACHED OUT TO McCARTHY'S
OFFICE FOR A RESPONSE BUT WE
HAVEN'T HEARD BACK.
SO JOINING ME NOW, CNN POLITICAL
DIRECTOR, DAVID, LISTEN, WE
CAUGHT PEOPLE IN LIES BEFORE ON
VIDEO TAPE.
WE'VE HEARD IT AND, YOU KNOW, ON
AUDIO TAPE AND STILL, THEY
SOMEHOW WRANGLE AND WIGGLE OUT
OF IT AND PRETEND IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
McCARTHY DENIED HE TOLD
COLLEAGUES THAT HE WOULD PUSH
TRUMP TO LEAVE OFFICE AND WE
JUST HEARD HIM IN HIS OWN WORDS.
SO WHAT?
>> YEAH, AND WHEN McCARTHY
OFFERED THE SLEEPING DENIAL
EARLIER TODAY, HE CLEARLY WASN'T
DEALING WITH THE PARTICULARS OF
THE REPORTING.
HE WAS JUST TRYING TO DISMISS IT
ALL IN ITS ENTIRETY WHICH, OF
COURSE, THIS IS A THOROUGHLY
REPORTED BOOK FROM TWO OF THE
BEST POLITICAL REPORTERS IN THE
BUSINESS.
IT SEEMED NOT THE BEST APPROACH
FROM McCARTHY TO JUST DISMISS IT
OUT OF HAND AND NOW, OF COURSE,
THEY HAVE THE GOODS TO BACK UP
THEIR REPORTING WITH THIS TAPE.
SO WHAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
HERE IS YES, IT IS A FASCINATING
INSIGHT, JUST FOUR DAYS AFTER
THE INSURRECTION, DON, TO HEAR
McCARTHY IN THIS CONVERSATION
WITH HIS LEADERSHIP TEAM ABOUT
THE PROSPECT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
BEING IMPEACHED.
IT'S AMAZING TO HEAR HIM SAY,
YOU KNOW, IT'S GOING TO PASS THE
HOUSE, AND THEY'RE GOING TO
CONVICT HIM IN THE SENATE EVEN
THOUGH HE'S GONE AND IT'S
EXACTLY THAT RATIONALE THAT HE
WOULD BE A FORMER PRESIDENT THAT
REPUBLICANS USED IN THE SENATE
TO NOT CONVICT HIM IN THE
IMPEACHMENT SO THIS IS A MOMENT
IN TIME AND THEN JUST WITHIN
DAYS OF THIS, YOU SAW KEVIN
McCARTHY, MITCH McCONNELL, ALL
BACK OFF THIS ATTEMPT TO TRY AND
DIMINISH TRUMP IN THE PARTY.
>> HOW DO YOU, AS A REPUBLICAN,
AND YOU'RE NOT A REPUBLICAN, BUT
JUST, YOU'RE AN ANALYST HERE,
HOW DO YOU, AS A REPUBLICAN,
BELIEVE ANYTHING THAT COMES OUT
OF KEVIN McCARTHY'S MOUTH OR ANY
OF THE OTHER FOLKS WHO DENY
THESE THINGS AND THEN THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE LYING?
HOW DO YOU CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THEM AND TO BE ON THE REPUBLICAN
AND THE TRUMP TRAIN?
IT IS INEXPLICABLE TO ME.
>> WELL, I MEAN, THERE ARE
BELIEVES ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
SO PROVEN FALSE IN REALITY, SUCH
AS THE LEGITIMACY OF THE 2020
ELECTION LIKE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT BARACK OBAMA INCLUDING
THAT IN HIS SPEECH OUT IN
CALIFORNIA, AND HIS SPEECH IN
CHICAGO A COUPLE WEEKS AGO ABOUT
HOW THE DISINFORMATION THAT HAS
SPREAD THAT NEARLY 40% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN
WASN'T LEGITIMATE ELECTED THAT
THE ELECTION WAS RIGGED, EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S BEEN PROOF THAT
THERE WAS NO WIDESPREAD FRAUD.
SO PEOPLE CAN BELIEVE IN WHAT
THEY WANT TO BELIEVE.
AS IT COMES TO WHETHER OR NOT
REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL, IN
McCARTHY'S CONFERENCE ARE GOING
TO BELIEVE HIS DENIAL, WELL,
WE'LL HAVE TO HEAR WHAT HIS
RESPONSE IS NOW THAT THE AUDIO
IS OUT THERE, BUT I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE ALL THAT INTERESTED IN
LITIGATING, WHETHER OR NOT
McCARTHY WAS TELLING THE TRUTH
WHEN HE DENIED THE STORY.
>> IS THERE ANY CHANCE THAT
THE -- YOU KNOW, WE TALKED ABOUT
FORMER PRESIDENTS AND YOU
ANSWERED THAT PART OF THE
QUESTION, I MEAN IT REALLY JUST
SORT OF BOLSTERS WHAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, BARACK OBAMA WAS
SAYING ABOUT THE BIG LIE, PEOPLE
JUST MAKING UP RIDICULOUS CLAIMS
AND YOU JUST HAVE TO PUT IT OUT
IN THE ECOSYSTEM, PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY HAVE TO BELIEVE IT IN
ORDER TO POISON THE WELL BUT ANY
CHANCE THE GOP WILL BREAK FROM
TRUMP, THE BIG LIE AND HIS
DISINFORMATION AT THIS POINT,
DAVID?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU ASKING ME IS
THERE ANY CHANCE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY BREAKS FROM TRUMP HAS NOW
BEEN A QUESTION FOR THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS, SINCE DONALD
TRUMP --
>> NO MATTER HOW MANY WAYS, I'LL
KEEP ASKING YOU AS MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS AS I CAN.
>> COMING ON TO THE SCENE, BUT,
YOU KNOW, WE'LL SEE IF DONALD
TRUMP MAINTAINS THE POWER HE
SEEMS TO STILL HAVE WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT DON, THIS
IS THE CONCERN HERE.
THIS IS WHY THIS IS BEYOND JUST
A POLITICAL INTRIGUE OF WHAT
McCONNELL AND McCARTHY THOUGHT
INITIALLY IN THE IMMEDIATE HOURS
AND DAYS AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
IT'S THEIR DECISION, ACTUALLY,
TO AQUIESCE TO TRUMP AND WHEN
THEY REALIZED THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THEIR OWN CONFERENCES BEHIND
THEM IN TAKING THEM ON OR TRYING
TO EX-COMMUNICATE HIM FROM THE
PARTY BECAUSE THE BASE OF THE
PARTY WAS NOT INTERESTED IN
DOING THAT, IT'S IN THAT MOMENT,
IT'S IN THAT MOMENT THAT THE LIE
WAS GIVEN NEW LIFE.
SO DONALD TRUMP LEAVES OFFICE
AND THEN CONTINUES TO SPOUT THE
LIE ABOUT ELECTION FRAUD TO THE
POINT THAT THERE'S A WHOLE
MOVEMENT NOW, TRUMP-ALIGNED
MOVEMENT TO GET PEOPLE ELECTED
INTO OFFICES WITH OVERSIGHT OVER
OUR ELECTIONS WHO ARE BLATANTLY
COMMITTED TO A FRAUDULENT STORY
ABOUT LEGITIMATE ELECTION.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE NEXT ELECTION
IF INDEED THESE FOLKS ARE IN
CHARGE OF THE ACTUAL VOTE COUNT.
>> I MEAN, IT IS FRIGHTENING,
AND NOT FRIGHTENING BECAUSE IT'S
REPUBLICANS, IT'S FRIGHTENING
BECAUSE IT'S BEING ALLOWED TO BE
DONE.
I MEAN LOOK AT WHAT RON DESANTEZ
IS DOING WITH FLORIDA, REDRAWING
THE LINES, THEN GETS TO APPROVE
IT HIMSELF, AND THEN WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE WHOLE
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE
ELECTION AND THE PEOPLE GOING TO
BE IN CHARGE OF THE ELECTION.
LISTEN, I THINK THIS IS PERSONAL
FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THIS
WHOLE IDEA THAT HE'S RAISING
THIS RED FLAG ABOUT
DISINFORMATION BECAUSE HE WAS
IT'S VICTIM, REMEMBER, OF THE
BIRTHER CONSPIRACY WHICH WAS A
LIE, NOW ANOTHER CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THREATENING OUR VERY
DEMOCRACY, THE MIDTERMS JUST
AROUND THE CORNER, DAVID, WHERE
IS THIS ALL HEADING?
I KNOW I'M TALKING TO YOU AS IF
YOU HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL BUT --
>> NO, IT'S PRECARIOUS.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS IN A PRECARIOUS
POSITION AND THAT'S WHY BARACK
OBAMA IS TALKING OF COURSE ABOUT
DEMOCRACIES AROUND THE WORLD BUT
ALSO, AS YOU NOTE, REALLY
RAISING THE ALARM ABOUT THE
DEMOCRACY, OUR DEMOCRACY RIGHT
HERE AT HOME AND HOW
DISINFORMATION IS DESTABILIZING
THE VERY FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY, THE FOUNDATION OF THE
DEMOCRACY, A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
AND SO YES, YOU'RE RIGHT, OBAMA
HAS A HISTORY OF THIS, THIS IS A
PASSION PROJECT OF HIS FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF HIS POST-PRESIDENCY.
HE'S CONSUMED BY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE HE SEES A
REAL POTENTIAL DANGER AND THAT'S
NOT JUST THIS NOBODY IN '22, IN
'24 AND BEYOND, THIS IS A CALL
TO STRENGTHEN THE PILLARS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IN THIS MOMENT BECAUSE
WE'RE IN A PERILOUS PLACE.
>> WE ARE, BECAUSE THIS IS
BEYOND -- AND I WANT PEOPLE TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
SAYING -- THIS IS NOT ABOUT LEFT
VERSUS RIGHT.
IF THIS WAS ABOUT LEFT VERSUS
RIGHT, IT WOULD BE WHAT ARE THE
PRINCIPLES ON THE LEFT, WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO DO FOR PEOPLE,
WHAT'S ON THE RIGHT, SMALL
GOVERNMENT, RIGHT, JACK KEMP AND
THAT SORT OF -- THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS IN A PLACE, NOW, OF
DISINFORMATION, OF LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND NO
MATTER HOW MANY TIMES PEOPLE SAY
THIS IS NOT MY REPUBLICAN PARTY,
THIS IS WHERE THEY ARE.
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE DO IT, THEY
DEFEND IT.
OR THEY DON'T SAY ANYTHING,
WHICH IS A PASSIVE, YOU KNOW,
DEFENSE WITHOUT SAYING ANYTHING.
IT'S A LIE OR A SIN OF OMISSION
SO THIS IS NO LONGER LEFT VERSUS
RIGHT, THIS IS ABOUT OUR
DEMOCRACY IN PERIL RIGHT
>> CERTAINLY A SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH SWATH OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY FITS WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING.
THERE'S EXAMPLES THAT'S NOT THE
CASE.
LIZ CHENEY WAS JUS